e
e e
time being um 11:31 I would like to uh
call our session uh we are here today
public hearing on Senate Bill 543
establishing a state environmental
adaptation resilience and Innovation
Council uh with that I would like to
recognize uh Senator Waters who Prime
sponsor of the legislation and welcome
you and all those here to public works
thank you well thank you Mr chairman uh
and members of the committee I'm Senator
David Waters uh from District 4 and here
to introduce Senate Bill 543 on the
stated environmental adaptation
resilience and Innovation Council and um
as I start Mr chairman I did want to
commend you all for the trific 10e plan
you put together and um you know I
really think it's great that this bill
ended up with you all because you're a
group that has you know deep wisdom on
how we how we plan on a regional basis
and uh how we make sure that taxpayer
money is saved and when we look at our
infrastructure across the across the
state so what this bill uh intends to do
is really to set up a a
planning um Economic Development and
risk avoidance uh Council and to look at
as the first sentence here says you know
given what's happening in New Hampshire
with our environmental changes and
storms and rainwater events and and so
forth that uh the state needs to look at
the kind of adaptation and uh Innovation
leadership um that we can do to help
residents communities particularly
businesses uh to be able to thrive in in
the future with with careful uh planning
um this is all about trying to save
taxpayer dollars in the future and it's
also about the importance of a planning
across agencies I will talk in a moment
about a lot of the good planning that
has been done kind of siloed off a
little bit and this would be an
opportunity for the agencies that are
listed on the council to come together
and to work together as other folks
doing in other other states um you know
it really is about comprehensive uh
contens of planning uh particularly
related to State infrastructure um I
want to thank uh so many people who have
helped with this um you know
particularly Health and Human Services
particularly Bob Scott commissioner
Scott um a lot of good help from uh
Homeland Security um Department of
Agriculture U fishing gameing you know
everybody listed here a lot of
conversations with about you know the
common sense of having them work
together on on planning and you will see
embedded in the bill many of the
suggestions that they made and and some
of the language too from these various
uh various departments
um and uh really the the the strategy
here is to to bring people uh together
and to look at how we can work across
these various areas um I should also
mention that there's been a lot of good
cooperation and contribution and
thoughts about how to work on this from
such groups as The Nature
Conservancy uh and others who as I will
mention a little bit later are willing
to help raise get some resources into
into helping this uh function well um we
have done a lot of previous studies and
planning um and some of them are now out
of date so it is time to look at them um
back in 2010 we had a public health
strategic plan um back around in 200 17
we had a weathering change um about uh
looking at what we can anticipate
through increased precipitation and uh
storm surge and and so forth um and
there was also a a a Business Leaders
report from 2017 on um risk avoidance
and risk resilience then of course in
2016 some of you may remember we had the
coastal risk and Hazards commission
report and uh you know with the support
of Governor sonunu that that report came
forward after commission H met to look
at the coastal area in particular the
risk and Hazards on the coast and
essentially to plan out how to do risk
and avoidance what what we could
anticipate in the in the future happen
on the coast and I think you know thank
goodness we put in Dot and others put
into Implement implemented some of the
things that came out of the commission
given what we've seen in the last few
months on the on the coast bad damage
but but could have been could have been
worse um we also have uh from fishing
game every 10 years they have to do
their Wild life action plan the last one
is 2015 um if you get their magazine uh
they're working on the 20125 and the
overall is managing for change um you
know what what do they see happening
with the the forests and uh fish fishing
game movements warming waters for brook
trout and so forth so as I said there a
lot of pockets off of good planning
going on um the doot in particular when
they took the report of the coastal risk
and Hazards commission uh we put in
statute that they had to use projected
sea level rise and that's why the the
new the $40 million bridge on 1A is 4
feet higher than it used to be smart
planning and I think that's what we need
to look at across uh across the
agencies now I didn't invent this out a
whole cloth because why not use the
models that exist and if you look around
you'll see that a lot of states are
doing this um I think particularly um
helpful to me was looking at Florida and
the counties down there are very very
powerful when it comes to to to planning
in infrastructure and the counties in
Florida have gotten together over the
last few years to put put forward things
just like this of how we're going to
plan um I think Texas is pretty
instructive too um not just around you
know Galveston to Houston area and the
coastal issues but then looking up to
the rest of the state where they're
seeing a drought we don't have a
wildfire problem but you know they
they've said we you know we we can't
just plan for one little area we got to
look look more broadly across it closer
to us um I've looked at the honic river
valley planning and uh that's
interesting because it's a watershed
that's very much like the northern half
of our state in some ways and uh they're
looking at okay what do we have to do to
make sure that our tourist economy our
our Fisheries our clean water and so
forth um are preserved across the wed uh
so that's that's Connecticut and uh
Massachusetts and and New York little
closer to home too you'll see that all
the states around us uh have something
very similar sometime in legislation
sometime in um you know Governor's order
um but particularly for for Maine uh
you'll see what they're trying to do
about the coast and they have a you know
very similar kind of thing here um I did
look kind of particularly to the state
of Pennsylvania because that's the first
state where there's been a comprehensive
economic study on what they can expect
to see on you know to roads to Ports uh
air conditioning schools uh heating
centers drought and so on on the
agriculture on the or on the forestry
big a much bigger State than we are but
they're projecting 11 to 12 billion
anticipated cost and so um they're some
other states are and uh cities are now
doing similar kind of trying to do some
cost projections and to figure out okay
if we're expecting these kinds of costs
what do we do about it how do we save
money and how do we adapt now so we
don't get uh hit with those um the last
thing as introduction I mention as well
is
that um I you see in this bill that kind
of bracketed off mitigation what they
call mitigation from adaptation
mitigation is what are we're doing about
energy and the department of energy got
$3 million Grant um from in yes from uh
the federal government to do an energy
action plan and that plan is the first
draft has been completed fantastic stuff
about Energy Efficiency and you know
what are ways we can reduce costs
through reducing energy costs and then
when we complete that the state will be
available for tens of millions of
dollars of Grants so that that that's on
the energy side this is about the
adaptation resilience side and that
that's why the the focus is that is is
here um if we could turn to the um bill
I will highlight uh some things um here
and uh let me um look to the page two
and who's on it and as I said I have uh
talked with all these folks and um
gotten some very good advice and learned
a lot about planning that is already
underway um in uh in those agencies a
couple of changes I note that the the
Senate um was asked to do uh
commissioner Jasper thought it' be
better than him on this to have the
director of New Hampshire agriculture
experiment station uh so you'll see that
on on uh um line 11 um and then as I
noticed uh noted on page uh on line 23
uh the nonprofit organizations who could
help us with some funding um and then uh
I will talk a little bit more about
somebody with expertise in climate uh
science and uh the state um
climatologist Mary stampone I don't know
she sent you a letter but I have a
letter from her that came into the
Senate saying she's more than willing to
to take on uh on on that um and then the
Bia I really appreciate the uh work with
the Bia and uh their inclusion on this
as as
well um we did a lot of work on the
Senate and trying to figure out just how
this would work um Department of
Environmental Services you will hear was
anxious about whether there potential
costs or Staffing that they would have
to provide because they certainly you
know could be a center of this activity
and you'll note that the bill does not
have a fiscal note because I think we've
dealt with that in some ways um you'll
see uh that while while the dees
commissioner will call the first meeting
that the dees commissioner is not
responsible for chairing or Staffing it
and there are Provisions in the bill um
for the seeking of grant funding and uh
I have some indications from Health
Homeland Security from HHS from do and
others that there might be funding that
they currently get that some of it could
be directed to help with a planning and
there is some commitment from the
nonprofits to try to raise some money as
was done for the castal risk and Hazards
commit to help with uh help with that
it's going to be twice a
year um and it only is going to take on
those you know this bill will probably
looks more complicated than it really is
I got the laundry list uh coming up but
it's only it's going to take on these
activities as they see fit and as seems
appropriate uh and hear reports about
what various agencies are doing so they
they can uh coordinate um with it I
think what's particularly important is
at the bottom of page two when I get
into one of the principles here um
Innovation and government
operations effective approaches that
build
resilience against environmental changes
protection of Public Health particularly
important to me is to Foster business
and Workforce Development we've got to
have a thriving economy whether it's the
tourist economy or the economy along the
on the coast um and then protecting the
taxpayer um let's let's look at how we
can save money for public investment um
for Public Safety and protect the
taxpayer um as well starting on page
three on line nine that all important
phrase subject to the availability of
resources so the commission the council
will have the um wisdom to decide what
they ought to look at when they ought to
look at it in these things let me just
point out a few things on the activities
here on line 11 on page three um it's
going to be important to have good maps
um what are we what are we looking at um
we have some good Maps now particular in
the Coter area there's a coastal mapper
which you can go online and find and you
can see if you want to project six in of
seal of AR rise or a storm surge from
like one of the northeaster we've had
you can see what areas might be
vulnerable the FEMA Maps down there and
then across the state too you know we
we've seen in the last 20 30 years about
a about a 25% increase in the annual
rainfall and also the extreme
precipitation events and that's why
blowing out culverts out in the western
part of the state or up North so we need
some good maps some some mapping and so
um that's why uh to look at the
available maps and if we think there
needs to be some more maps than um
perhaps University of Hampshire other
places are doing this now can help them
um with that and then um coordinated
planning that's that's really the heart
of it start line 15 is to you know take
a look at the planning you're already
doing and are there gaps there about
looking to the future I mean a lot lot
of our planning is kind of reactive
sometimes you know home and security
something goes bad how we going to deal
with a crisis but proactive planning um
and even in a 10-year plan you know
where we have put in statute that they
have to use certain um criteria for
determining what future sea rise in the
Sea Coast Area uh is or groundwater
intrusion and so forth um on road
condition um then may be that some other
agencies uh need to start looking
forward uh to this adaptation and that's
you'll see some of the ones that are
named there which I think um that they
could look at and then coordinate that
planning um it probably is awfully good
for do and fishing game to get together
if it looks like animals going to be
moving into different areas or um you
know have to look at what's going to
happen with Stream flow and culs and
need for brook trout or whatever to be
able to move to cooler Waters the this
is the kind of getting together I'm
talking about um
and also uh look at the ways in which um
the coast so I you know take another
look at the 2016 report for the coast
RIS hazards um as I said we have a
rather out ofd um Public Health Report
and uh HHS is very enthusiastic about
getting back into planning about uh
Public Health particularly with heat um
and air quality uh allergies as it gets
warmer i' I've got I've got allergies
right and they're coming earlier every
year um so these are the public health
things that they they think we ought to
um look at and then uh section e there
um there's already a lot of talk about
what are we going to do about air
conditioning um whether it's state
buildings or particularly Public Schools
um what are we going to have to do it's
uh my district of Summers worth they had
a two classrooms they couldn't use
starting in May and they had to spend a
lot of money to redo the the hbac to
take care of of that so we ought we
ought to you know and what kind of
public State resources might we be
looking at to deal with some of those uh
things and really to Mr chairman to the
heart of this committee um FG and H I
mean this is your sweet spot on this
committee um State what how we going to
have more resilient
Transportation what are future funding
needs for enhance of the storm drainage
roads Bridges I I mentioned the you know
the 4 foot elevation of routee 1A and uh
where those other Coastal roads going to
be elevated how we going to do it how we
going to pay for it I I don't really see
how municipalities themselves can
shoulder all these costs um so I think
we got to start seeing what we can do um
there and uh state funded facilities
State facilities um you know we spent a
lot of money on capital budget the last
few years looking at roofs that need to
replace on various state buildings and
uh we we probably ought to get ahead of
that a little bit as as well um and then
you know I'm thank goodness we got the
$2 million from the feds last week for
the coastal seaw wall rebuild um next
big
storm is it going to blow them all out
again um so we really need to and our
ports too um you know portter Portsmouth
we were putting tens of millions of
dollars into the port there to create a
larger deck and to make it um more able
to handle ships that are coming in
whether it's for offshore wind or you
know everything else that's handled down
there um but that Port facility is an
economic engine and we have to you know
kind of that's another thing we're going
to be looking at because the state
spends money uh on on that the next one
and I is really about Homeland Security
and HHS uh and again this is written
with the advice of both of them in the
language there uh a lot of good talks
with the um Timberland Owners
Association Department of Agriculture
culture about what are we anticipating
about forests um you know as uh
migrating pests are coming in and we're
seeing threats to our forest I mean my
God we're losing white we're losing Ash
the sprute budworms all these all these
uh threats to our forest that we see
slowly marching uh North and and it's
not just the forest products but it's
also tourism um that we got to kind of
look at what what we can do about
adaptation to make make sure our tourist
economy up north um Can Survive I think
particularly important as well Mr
chairman for this committee and thinking
about the state assets is uh section k
um what are the revenue impacts likely
to
be uh
if the change continues the way it is if
we have the inability to maintain the
same length of the ski season or um
along the coast with the beaches um what
are the impacts of revenues uh going to
be also a lot of the Credit raing
Agencies Moody's and others are already
um starting to use uh a look at if there
is resilience planning um in terms of
when they give their bond rating for
municipalities and for States
so that's going to be important in terms
of the cost of the taxpayer if we get
better Bond ratings because we plan for
resilience and adaptation that's going
to help the taxpayer as
well um I think also particularly
insurance insance costs um you know we
we we probably ought to take a good look
at that uh I I thought back and forth
about having insurance commissioner on
here but it seemed better to just
consult with the insurance commissioner
as as uh as as needed um and then uh the
heart of it too in L make recommendation
on Pro potential funding to protect New
Hampshire taxpayers from bearing the
full Co burden of costs and to explore
Innovative financing as I say I I don't
don't know how we can burden our
municipalities and the taxpayer with all
the costs that might be anticipated so
what we can what can we look for for
Grants and if we have a good planning
process like that we have a leg up on
being able to get the federal grants
they look to they look to us having
something uh like like this um and just
a few minutes more Mr chairman I'm sorry
to go for so long but I did want to walk
us through you you do have great breath
quality I'm me
I was a professor for 39 years and I
could fill 40 minutes like that okay but
I won't do it please please continue
s um I think some coming from the lesson
of the castal risk and Hazards
commission when we went into that there
was a lot of um dispute over what are we
really looking at and what can we
anticipate particularly for storm
surgeon SE of Horizon on the coast so we
thought what was best was establish a
separate group that could look at a
Baseline
of what the commission could use and I
thought that would make sense here we're
not talking about a lot of new
sciencetific research the the research
is available but here's where the state
climatologists and some other folks who
get together say to the commission
across the state here's the best guess
of what you need to look for and that
will give a baseline for the uh
commission um to to look at
um and uh then let's last part of the
bill gets down to the financing uh how
we're going to how we're going to find
some dollars and um so you'll see bottom
of page four the working groups um and
the the council itself can look to
federal grants and other
sources uh there very important to
Senator berdo was that we include on
page on line
35 that it is the legislature which
controls the money so that here it says
the reception of such funds shall
require the approval of the joint fiscal
committee if the joint fiscal committee
is not comfortable with the source of
any funds it can say no and I think
that's important Gate Keeper function
you also see an important gatekeeper
function uh on page
five um where we set up this fund that
can receive federal grants and other and
uh private nonprofits Report with uh and
it says okay fine but before you spend
any of
that you've got to get the approval of
joint fiscal or when necessary the
governor's counsel we're the legislative
branch we need to make sure that the
funding is looked at a little bit
earlier in the bill too um I neglected
to mention this but there is a a
sentence here um that says that uh it is
the state which is the primary authority
over any policy this is not a group to
make policy the legislature makes policy
so we thought it was important to have
in the in this bill that statement that
this council is not supposed to go off
and create policy for the state it's
supposed to advise us and make
recommendation to us about what we might
want to enact upon their uh
experience um so it sets up a fund uh as
you'll see here and that's pretty
standard language um about how the fund
is set up accept funding um if and there
is I would just mention um there is a
lot of funding right now in the ira bill
for this kind of activity um there is
substantial funding for um uh
agriculture U from the agriculture
department for this kind of activity
there's substantial funding in homeland
security for this kind of activity from
the federal government there's
substantial funding on Coastal uh and on
water projects and uh for transportation
so you know I think that this this
provides um kind of an an impetus for
this group to look to the federal
dollars where they can get them uh and
bring some of those resources into into
the
state Mr chairman thank you for
indulging me thank you uh for your
testimony questions for
senator represent clear okay thank you
Mr chair do do you in in your opinion
and uh do you see this Council
as uh trying to coordinate agencies of
the executive branch in in responding to
to climate change and and also another
thing you see it maybe they could issue
legis uh recommendation to the
legislative branch for consideration of
different bills if necessary if they
find a problem that they can't work out
within the executive
branch well thanks for the question and
and I agree with a good part of that I
think environmental change is something
all the agencies are fa are facing and
um so two things it lets them say work
together work together um we don't
really you know since we got rid of the
office of U of planning we don't really
have this function centralized anymore
we peeled off the energy stuff in the
department of energy but you know here
here's a lot of the rest things they
used to do and um uh so I think that
that that cross agency will be important
um I don't see this Council as saying a
a peep about bills that we put in the
legislature I think can make
recommendations to us but you know the
agenc you know it's like the agencies
come in and advise us on on bills so I I
I I do really want to have a bright line
between their being a very practical
group that looks at it's a planning
exercise and it's a regional and across
the state coordination exercise and what
comes from that will be potentially
advised to us reporting uh uh to us and
it's about um you know I really it's
environmental MH at a a um other people
can worry about you know energy and all
that stuff as I said this is about what
do we what do we know we got to do to
protect the taxpayer and what are we
going to look at so and I will add
mention as well that I I know the
chairman has some ideas about changing
some of the language here uh maybe you
know some of the composition of the of
the of the council and as I said at the
start this is a wise committee you know
how to do this kind of stuff so the
advice that you have will be welcome Mr
chair followup please thank you for your
compliment uh but you see it sort of
more and I just want to be clear I
understand sort of coordinating the
state's response to our adapting weather
CL whatever you call it and I don't want
to get into argument about climate
change today but are adapting and how
are we going to deal with what is
happening and may be happening already
right a sort of a coordinated response
by agencies in the state the executive
branch yeah thank you coordination and
then individually as they do the
planning they already do to add on this
layer of let's look to the Future uh
with this lens so thank you okay thank
you thank you represent
bone thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so you've got
about 20 people on this Council you meet
twice a year and you're going to come up
with a report so my question is because
I think this is a great idea and because
what happens is we've got all these
different agencies and we have the
problem of what's the the jargon today
is silos everyone's working
independently of each other they all see
the problem in the same with their own
narrow interests and so this is a group
that's going to step back and say okay
let's take a a holistic look at the
state which I think is a really good
idea I'm just wondering how I mean
functionally who's going to ride Herd on
this group so basically who's going to
basically to make sure that the group
meets
and is there so how does the the
operation of the council
work thank you for the for the question
and
um the language you see here is the
result of a lot of conversation with
Dees and the anxieties about putting a
burden on staff that they may or may not
have um it can meet more than twice a
year I think functionally it will again
the example of the cised hazard
commission that what we did there was to
break into
subgroups and to say that there were
subgroups to go off and work on a
particular area where it seemed to make
sense you know to come come together uh
and that they could do a lot of the work
and that what what would happen is that
then they would come together at least
twice a year to receive those kinds of
reports and so forth this group I mean I
I really I mean we have fabulous State
Commissioners and agency heads right you
know I mean these people are doing are
doing great jobs and I think they'll get
together they'll elect some leaders
leadership they'll set a meeting
schedule um I think they are going to
get a lot of help from folks and from
Grants and from the nonprofits to help
them U you know take care of some staff
functions for this so I think it'll work
um
yeah thank you and and thank you for
that answer so so pretty much so so you
see Dees as taking the lead in this that
the way the Bill's written to get things
started is that correct thanks for the
question they'll call the first meeting
um and then the uh you'll see the
council can elect a chair or
co-chairs so uh I had a lot of
discussion with you know maybe it makes
sense if Dees and HHS it's co-chairs and
H says well you know maybe maybe not but
that's something they can uh work out
about how they're going to organize um
themselves and they're good at this and
I I just didn't you know Dees obviously
is going to have a lot to do with this
but I did not want to force a
commitment no fysical note in the bill I
wanted them to be able to get started
and then they all going to look at their
budgets and the grants that I think will
come in in the next year so so they'll
be able to you know figure out what they
can do on that so
I you know I if I could M wave a magic
wand and uh you know strike gold
somewhere but I I think you know we do
things frugally in the state right we
get together we we work together and
this is this encourages that thank you
thank you repent pulner D question thank
you I think you may have yeah address
this question but to what extent uh
would it be possible or or advisable to
have this group hire an outside agency
outside firm to produce some of the
technical information and then possibly
report is that within the
scope thanks for the um for the question
um I think that there is going to be an
opportunity um that's why I had the the
state climatologist and Mary STP point I
think there's in the mapping I think
there's a lot of existing information
here that can be provided to it um and
uh in terms
of the capacity to have if they're you
know to help have some help there I do
think some of the nonprofits are willing
to undertake some fundraising to help
with that what I think makes the most
sense though is that for the agencies
involved here and I mentioned several
that you know do do planning and you
know regularly most of them do but that
are more particularly related to this
they'll have an opportunity the way the
bill is
structured in their budget presentations
to the governor and when we all the
budget next year if they decide that
they think that they could play a the
their role in this or just in planning
in general could use some financial
support that's the budget process again
it's in the legislature which is where
where it belongs so I think there's a
lot of possibilities and um I think
we'll get it done thank you further
questions uh yes orim mels
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this is purely
mechanical now yeah um as far as funds
ex expenditure funds may be expended
upon the recommendation of the council
and I heard you un I understood
correctly this the legislation is going
to have a big part in it also so my
mechanical question is let's just say
the the council decides that they have
to spend x amount they want to recommend
x amount of dollars be spent on Pro B
and they take it to the joint physical
committee and the phisical committee
says yes great it's a great
idea is that good enough for approval
for this particular project or does this
mechanically
require a a bill to come through the
legislature that says you've got to take
x amount of dollars for Project B and
it's already been preapproved yeah so so
nothing is going to be expended directly
through the council it'll have to come
through the legislature thanks for the
question and um the way I've imagined it
is that um the language here is uh joint
physical which is the legislature um but
that is a process for so if funds come
in from
Grants so they have funding it's not
asking for new state appropriation right
okay so it's funding comes in through
grants either to the agency or into this
fund they have to go to join fiscal and
then of course it's a contract cont ract
it's got to go to the governor counsel
right if they want to ask in the for a
budget you know a general fund
appropriation expenditure that's got to
go
through a bill or the budget process
right so correct the language here is
particularly around the creation of that
fund how you going to feed it how you
going to take money out of it they can
make
recommendations that say hey we go we
just we just got $100,000 Grant from the
feds we'd like to use it for this
planning activity
um but they can't write the check it
would have to go through joint fiscal
and as appropriate to the U executive
Council so thank you s yeah but I mean
you know if you think that language need
to be typ up typen up or changed to
clarify
anything thank you uh thank you for your
testimony sener thank you Mr chairman
I'd like to move to Ted Ted I always
have problem deers de thank you please
come please come forward sorry I didn't
see it when I walked in all right good
to see you Mr
chair thank you very much uh for the
record my name is Ted deers and I am the
assistant director of The Water Division
at the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services and it's a
tremendous pleasure to be in front of
you here today so uh been certainly
working with uh Senator waters on this
bill now for several months as well as
with the other agencies and I would like
to just do a couple of things today um
one is to say first of all that the
changes that were made as amended
through the Senate um made this bill
much more palatable um we had a lot of
concerns originally about the amount of
uh Dees staff time that this would take
and I would just say that I've been with
the state for 27 and A2 years and then
in that time I've never seen around me
every single person being at or Beyond
capacity uh as we are today uh there's a
lot of reasons for that but it is um
right now that that you know all staff
time is a concern so that's uh one of
the concerns that was addressed I was
also concerned that this was a
NeverEnding uh proposition um and so
you'll see that it also does have sort
of a beginning a middle and an end and I
think that that's important um to this
uh to this effort it's also an
opportunity for me to brag a little bit
about some of the great work that Dees
is doing uh we are um you know I think
that we're doing a full court press at
this moment on all of the kinds of
issues that have been discussed here we
on our Sea Coast Area we've been doing
this for a very long time because those
are the places that are both flat so you
get lots of issues with precipitation
and they bump up against the ocean and
the ocean's coming up to get us so we
got the mountains coming down and we got
the ocean coming up and uh you know
that's a challenge in our Sea Coast so
that's certainly the place where we've
done a ton of of stuff we recently
funded uh the state climatologist to
take some of the good work that had been
done looking at what are the potential
uh environmental hazards that we may be
facing in the future from just the Sea
Coast to Statewide so there's a really
good report that was just created by the
state climatologist that takes those
those models downscales them across the
state and we are able to understand what
some of those impacts are from from
Berlin to to Handover uh to uh to Keane
uh and and everywhere in between so that
that's a good rhyme I'm going to put
that in a song uh one of these days
um a couple of other things going on
that that you may not know about we uh
have recently hired two people in our
drinking water and wastewater programs
uh that are looking specifically at
doing vulnerability assessments of our
water our clean and and drink uh clean
water sewer uh infrastructure as well as
the drinking water infrastructure and
storm water infrastructure so that's all
kind of going on right now so they're
working directly with uh FEMA programs
as well as with those particular
communities and water suppliers on
making sure that what they are doing
will be uh less vulnerable to Future
impacts uh whether it be energy shocks
uh that is for pricing or it be uh the
you know floods or other kinds of things
also today we launched uh a new study
looking at emergency interconnectedness
of our Sea Coast uh water supplies so
this is all the communities in the Sea
Coast participating through a consulting
firm uh that we're going to look at how
would we provide for water during
emergencies that could happen in a
particular Community this is
extraordinarily important work as we see
more and more of these kinds of issues
come up so that's really key uh we have
AR arpa funds that we recently put $6
million towards uh Statewide culverts so
we have Culver scaling in across the
state to upssize those culs to handle
increased flow we have a project that's
going to be in front of govern and
Council on next Wednesday in uh the
community of South aworth um which is a
lovely spot if you've been there there's
a brook there that is completely
unraveled and is coming out of its banks
and trying to wash out a DOT uh Culvert
as well as the General Store uh that is
in South aworth which is by the way run
by the community itself uh by volunteers
it's pretty spectacular great sandwiches
um and um so we have a lot going on and
we also working closely with Dot in the
Sea Coast uh looking at culverts and
looking at Route 1A and understanding
what's going to be happening with both
salt marsh the natural side as with as
well as with the infrastructure itself
so we have a lot going on um I could go
on and on about all the different work
that is going on right now and there's a
lot of funding out there so I think that
that is important so um I would just uh
end saying that I think that Dees is
certainly uh capable of you know hosting
the first meeting um and uh and
launching this sort of thing we if
that's uh your wish uh we certainly are
capable of doing that and we would bring
the information that we have to whatever
kind of council is set up um you know
obviously we'd love to share the
information that we would have other
than that I would be just um willing to
you know answer any questions that that
you might have for us and um then we can
chat further thank you thank you
Commissioners
um yes reper please
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you for
uh taking my comment a question I might
be a do you believe thing but um the SE
Coast drinking water uh commission um is
the one that worked on the uh the issue
you just mentioned and I'm surprised in
some ways you didn't tie that in because
this that commission is the one that
ended up generating you know the work
that's being done right right and I
apologize I should have said that yep
yeah and um you know Brendan k and it's
just unbelievable uh you know helping uh
and guiding that and we're getting ready
to have a meeting soon but I just wanted
to mention that cuz it is so positive
thank you absolutely and I I I was I was
remiss in not mentioning that that
committee is has a a full work plan uh
that incorporates you know a lot of
different aspects I think that cross
some of the things that have been talked
about here from public health to
contamination issues to um you know
natural disasters so that that all I
think is Incorporated in the the great
work and that's a great commission we're
enjoying working with them so thank you
for bringing that up thank you represent
balone thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so in the
letter uh from commissioner Scott
there's a a line that says we believe
that a a position would be needed to
staff the effort it's right about in the
middle of that so can you kind of Flesh
that out what what what do you think
that is it a position that Dees would
because I think You' talked about being
stretched as it right thank you for the
question and I think that um you know we
don't need to have uh for this effort
it's an important effort Dees doesn't
need to own it so I I think our hope and
this is what I think Senator uh Waters
was talking about and what I think has
been the discussion over the last few
months is that other parties could step
up finding resources to bring some
staffing to Bear our experience the only
reason we say that is that our
experience with these sorts of
committees and these sorts of councils
is that if you can have someone in a
coordinating position who's not sitting
on the committee that is that you know
not the actual member who's sitting on
the committee it doesn't really matter
what agency that's in but having someone
who can help to coordinate will do
exactly I think the question came up
about what can you get done doing two
meetings a year it's having that set of
resources to be able to make sure that
you have continuity from meeting to
meeting if there's subcommittees
tracking The Works of those
subcommittees um so I think that's what
one of the it was a recommendation that
we have but not necessarily that it has
to be in our budget I I I don't you know
I don't feel like I need to Empire build
in this direction uh if that was the
question okay thank you any further
questions yes representative bit excuse
me thank thank you Mr chair
um hope I can remember what I was going
to say to you but
uh you know W with the commission that
know the Drinking Water Commission
in in the work it's doing um one of the
things that has helped um is that there
have been there there are a couple
members from from the legislature you
know both the Senate and the house
mostly the house
and you already have 17 members being
suggested for this this commission I
didn't see any um senators or
Representatives mentioned there and at
times it has helped to
generate um recommendations
um because of the relationship we have
with the bills that are being put in and
also recommendations for bills that
we've that have been made that um
there's there's nobody I was going to
mention this to Senator Waters but
there's do you think there should be
somebody there even though it makes it
you know 17 is unbelievable but uh to
make it even uh I want to say more
unwieldy but as long as you get people
working on it it's fine having a large
number so thanks for the question uh um
you know I think this is uh at this
point this is your bill um and so it's
really your wisdom uh brought to the
bear my experience is similar to yours
uh representative Edgar is that um on
the various different committees and
commissions that I've had the pleasure
of working on having a legislative voice
has been particularly important um I
think about the recent
cyanobacteria uh committee that we
recently had and um uh chair renz Zulo
sat uh in that committee
um not in a leadership role but in the
role that I think you're suggesting that
is to bring the voice of the legislature
and the policy makers uh into that as
well as to carry the message from the
committee back uh to his committee uh
which is you know key for that
particular subject so it seems like a a
reasonable recommendation uh to me thank
you thank you any further
questions thank you thank you for your
time yeah for represent edar I have had
conversations with Senator waters on
that subject and I believe you know the
displeasure of the speaker to bring
forward new commissions and committees
and if we brought on a legislative
person then we would be bound to make up
a certain percentage of that committee
and with 17 it would take quite a few
legislators Andor Senators so that
that's why it was structured in this way
but we can certainly consider it
uh thank thank you Mr chair I didn't
realize there was a percentage uh
requirement thank you there is okay I
would like to recognize uh John Evans
from New Hampshire Department of
Transportation
welcome thank you representative my name
is John Evans I'm with the Bureau of
environment of the Department of
Transportation I'm the project
management section chief um I'm here
just today mainly to to express uh
support for this bill by the Department
of
Transportation um we we at the
department uh have a very robust
environmental review process that we
follow and uh we coordinate closely with
Dees and fishing game and many of our
other uh re natural resource agencies uh
both at the state and federal level and
um as you can imagine the uh you know
the with recent storms and stuff the
these these can really uh
create uh quite a quite a burden
financially on the department so we we
uh we support any any kind of uh
planning level efforts which would would
allow us
to um you know plan appropriately and
try to
to ensure that we have the appropriate
resources as we as we move into the into
the future and so we we kind of look at
this uh this committee as as really a
sounding board for us to to identify
needs uh make sure that they get into
the trans you know the 10-year
plan um you know we we obviously we we
already are uh you know utilizing much
of the science uh in in you know
included in climate change uh we we
participate uh as as Senator Waters
mentioned in the coastal risk and
Hazards uh commission and um but we we
utilize there's there's a lot of
different data out there um to to guide
us but this would be a great kind of
spot to kind of focus all of the the
information and kind of give us a good
spot to start with um to really say okay
these These are the priorities and the
these are how the department should try
and allocate resources appropriately um
as as you can imagine um you know
generally when we when we think of
climate change we often think and
transportation particularly we often
think okay we either need to go up and
or out um we need more space uh because
you know the the the water requires more
more room it requires more you know it
results in higher higher water levels
during storm events and whatnot um so
what that means is that the
Transportation infrastructure also needs
to go up and out um but what that can
result in often times is actually
additional environmental
impacts um and so you know when you look
at at that in the near term um you know
you kind of one of the one of the goals
of the department and and our procedures
you know which are uh greatly focused on
the National Environmental Policy Act
which is essentially to just a avoid
environmental impacts when you can
minimize them if you can't and then
mitigate kind of as a as a as necessary
in accordance with the the rules and
regulations now again going back to what
I was saying before about how when when
you're going up when the transportation
system has to go up and out you're going
to have additional environmental impacts
now sometimes those can be if you're
looking at the just the
project in the in the current situation
you may have um you may not end up being
able to the
the the additional you may end up with
some additional environmental impacts
but it's hard to justify those
environmental impacts to go up uh if
you're uh you know from an from a
minimization standpoint so essentially
you know if we build this bridge larger
we may need larger a UTS and it may need
to go higher in the embankments and may
be larger that requires more uh more
environmental impact so essentially what
I'm trying to say here is that this this
committee would help us focus on on
hitting the right spot as to how how
high do we need to go how wide do we
need to go those kinds of things there's
there's a lot of different information
out there at the state and federal level
um and certainly anytime that we we
participate in a committee and can
demonstrate
to uh the the resource agencies that
we've we've considered some of the the
information from a from a a committee
such as this that says okay we think
that you should be designing roadways
for you know for this elevation at this
particular location that then then we
can go to those resource agencies and
say
hey because the because of this standard
that was set we actually need to
increase our Environmental
impacts um beyond the that which if
you're just looking at that particular
project may be we we probably could
minimize our impacts more but in the
long run it may be beneficial for the
environment and the the the communities
to actually have additional
environmental impacts and and obviously
getting that support from the resource
agencies such as such as Dees uh and
fishing game and whatnot would would
greatly assist us and having them on the
committee uh would would provide us with
that opport opportunity to gain that
support so
um but uh uh I guess other than that I
um I I would also uh like to add to I I
agree with Senator Waters that uh
participating in a in a committee such
as this does uh put us in a better
position for Grants grant
opportunities um as as I think many of
us may have heard uh just recently we
got a grant for that to to uh to to
address some of the issues related to
the rment wall out in uh the on the on
the Sea Coast in Northampton um that you
know those are the types of grant
opportunities that are out there that um
participating in this committee and
saying hey we're already this that we're
designing to the standard that they've
they've recommended uh that and
therefore we need this additional money
for for whatever that may be um so and
and then also this would help us assist
in and going back to what I mentioned
previously just in making sure that that
we prioritize properly as we we put
projects into the 10-year plan um so
with that I'll entertain any questions
that thank you any questions for
rans seeing none oh yes
please thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking me my question I'm trying
to wrap my head around what's being said
here
today you know first of all I would
think why doesn't the executive branch
already
have a council or committee to review
everything everybody's doing to try to
get everybody on the same page and
realistically do you think the committee
what everybody saying this committee is
going to do realistically can be done in
two meetings a
year thank you for the question I I I I
feel we certainly already have there are
some resources out there but uh and you
know for example the uh the coastal risk
hazards uh commission is is a uh is a
great resource out there but there
are this committee not only focuses on
say the coast but it would also focus on
some of the more Inland areas which may
not have as much uh as many advisory
resources available to it so I I
certainly uh feel that there is benefit
in having having a a a larger um you
know presence a committee that can
address at the at the larger level
because there's you know many of the the
storm events aworth is aworth is a great
example uh we've been working uh
diligently with with Dees uh you know
through our normal process but uh but
having having you know the
the having had coordination at the kind
of the planning stage rather than the
design stage would provide additional
benefits to the department and that's
really where where this would you know
we feel that this would be provide the
greatest benefit is more at the at the
planning stage because the you know once
we get to design we have the resources
you know the resources that are
available have already been allocated
and you know we have to work within
those those limits uh whereas if we know
how what is necessary we can make sure
that the proper amount of funds are in
the 10year plan and whatnot and that's
that's really uh where we feel the
advantages of this this committee would
be thank you yes
followup thank you for taking my
followup uh page
two
line 32 says again it shall meet at
least two times annually
that just doesn't even seem realistic to
me would you favor or do you think
quarterly four times annually should be
in
here um I think I think to start with
two times may be a great a good spot to
start and I think I'm I'm
I'm anticipating that you know this this
may be one of those where we we try it
out see how it goes and if it really is
looking like hey there's a lot of
advantages and we may need to meet more
frequently um then then the committee
might meet more frequently um I I
believe Senator Waters did mentioned
that you know it's kind of it's a
starting point um and that that you know
the design may may kind of come out as
we as the committee would start to meet
thank you thank you I'd just like to
caution all that are uh participating
the conversation we were speaking about
a council not a committee we're not
talking about a commission apologize
believe me I'm the last one to correct
someone I just I just need there there
are different parameters for what we're
talking about here and having been on
the pleasure I don't know if it's the
pleasure sometimes of of being the chair
of commissions uh what I see happening
um representative Newton your your
thoughts on how much could get done the
first meeting there is not going to get
much done but my my assume my assumption
is that direction will be given all
these people so that their second
meeting is productive when they come
into the third and fourth meeting you
know they're up and they're up and
running was there someone else with a
question okay thank you uh seeing no
further thank you
sir I'd like to recognize uh Nick
kof am I somewhere near correct there
sir from conservation law
Foundation yes that's please you just
handam the end and we'll pass them along
thank you sir sir welcome to public
works yeah thank you very much um Nick
cof with the conservation law foundation
and you did pronounce it correctly um
most people don't so I commend you on
that it's my um but yeah so yeah as I
said I'm with the conservation law
Foundation um and I'm here to urge you
to support this bill today you know just
over the past year alone we've seen a
lot of severe weather affecting the
state um you know we saw flash flooding
um in the Upper Valley in manad regions
um last July it was it was a huge storm
you know with four or five Ines of rain
in just one day and um you know some
small towns were just decimated and the
damage to the towns particularly aworth
which Dees mentioned earlier um I think
32 roads and and stream you know roads
are washed out um you know the estimate
to to that damage is you know cost
around $20 million and you know this
town has a budget of like a million and
a half so you know this is this is
decimating these towns budget
um you we've seen other storms this
storm this last December um you know
severely hit North
Conway um you know the White Mountains
region yeah we saw us flooding in in
Hampton um you know in January and have
seen actually flooding a few times this
winter and so you know this this is a
huge problem um you know we need to
start planning for for what's happening
with these severe storms you know
they're they're happening more
frequently and um you these small towns
you know the state you know need to
prepare for them because otherwise
they're just going to blow apart these
budgets year after year um and so having
a council like this that can um you know
plan for develop adaptation and
resilience strategies is what we really
need um to get you know to ensure that
um you know budgets don't get blown
apart and that we develop the
infrastructure needed to um you know to
adapt and and uh to some of the severe
weather um you know I once STC that is
in the the comments which I passed
around is that Noah estimates that there
were three major weather events last
year in 2023 that are estimated to have
cost the state between1 and $250 million
so you know there's the two um December
and the July flooding events and then
there was a a cold front last February
but those those three events you know
cost the state a ton of money and so um
we need to start planning for you know
to to develop infrastructure structure
that can really um adapt to this change
that we're seeing um to adapt to this
extreme weather um you know also there's
the public health impacts that we're
seeing from from events like this um so
we need to adapt to that as well and so
you the failure to plan ahead is just
going to mean that you budgets get blown
apart and that physical infrastructure
continually gets um you know gets
destroyed by these these weather systems
um and so I urge you to support this
bill I think it's sorely needed and um
happy to take any questions from any of
the Reps here today thank you thank you
any
questions thank you
sir just might want to throw in in my
district Madison
Tamworth and uh aipe into your list of
towns that were
devastated I would like to uh Kristen K
from business and industry Association
of New Hampshire Bia and I love that you
say 2 minutes worth of testimony
so I'm all yours I'm typically very
Speedy uh thank you for the opportunity
um for the record my name is kirston
cotch I'm the vice president of public
policy for the business and industry
Association known as Bia and we serve as
the Statewide Chamber of Commerce um we
are here today in support of this bill
um we value the opportunity for this
Council to address uh important concerns
regarding environmental impact on public
health infrastructure tourism natural
resources water Innovation and to Foster
business and workplace development while
also uh leveraging key relationships
between um communities businesses
environmental and health organizations
educational institutions and government
um our members particularly value the
opportunity that this Council brings
because it um has is charged with work
that would be proactive rather than
reactive and we see that as really
beneficial for the state um ultimately
this bill was amended um in the Senate
and the sponsor so kindly added a seat
for the business and industry
Association um just to be completely
transparent that was not a seat that we
requested but we are uh very grateful to
have the opportunity to be a part of
this Council um we believe we can help
by bringing in experts from industry and
uh uh specifically uh the sponsor uh
indicated interest in the insurance
industry and and sharing their
perspective and how they can be helpful
going forward um ultimately we believe
that this bill has good um thoughtful
precautions so we would respectfully
encourage committee to pass this Bill
thank you I'd be happy to take any
questions other questions Madam Kos yes
please thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so would Bia
be interested in uh Staffing this
group uh thank you for the question I
believe it would be the purview of the
council to elect a chair um we'd be
happy to serve in whatever capacity is
necessary though I feel that we're
probably not the main character in this
story and so uh we'll we'll serve the
role that would be appropriate for us
thank you further
question a mind to you are you the one
that generates the legislative scorecard
because maybe we should
talk that is the role of our policy
staff as a whole thank you thank you for
your thank
you um the last uh person last pin card
I have here is for uh Meredith I believe
it's Hatfield and Matt Thorne if you
want to come forward uh the nature
conservancy and you are our last
speakers and um please uh have a seat
introduce yourselves and welcome to
public
works thank you very much my name is
Meredith Hatfield with the nature
conservancy and with me is Matt Thorne
and he focuses on uh climate adaptation
for our office we've been working in New
Hampshire for over 60 years on a range
of environmental issues and we are
increasingly focused on resilience
working with agencies and communities to
help them become more resilient uh there
are three things that I just handed out
to you the first is our testimony letter
um the second is something that um my
colleague is going to talk to you about
in a minute um a two-pager about
building uh flood resilience in New
Hampshire and then the third thing is a
group letter from a bunch of our
colleagues um and I won't read them all
to you uh you can see them right there
on the page um but they are eight other
partner uh nonprofit groups who not only
support the bill but who I also think
could bring some uh important
information and support to the council
if you choose to pass the legislation
and we do strongly support the bill um
so I'm going to turn it over to Matt and
he's going to talk to you about
culbert's one of his favorite
things everyone's favorite thing Matt
Thorne from The Nature
Conservancy uh so why is the nature
conservancy uh entering into this
adaptation work because we're not
keeping up with the weather um that is
wreaking havoc on our infrastructure but
we can build to work with nature and
work with the streams and rivers uh and
not fight it so to sum sum it up uh very
simply an ounce of prevention is worth a
pound of cure or I should probably say
an ounce of well coordinated prevention
is worth a pound of
cure um I do get to work in the world of
culverts a little bit which I feel that
some folks on this committee may have
experience with or or familiarity with
we just finished up a project on topaz
drive right off Route four in barington
uh and I bring it up because it's a
classic example of where New Hampshire
finds itself in in places and at times
with its infrastructure and some of the
photos you'll see in the two-pager are
called colorful examples of what happens
um when uh when we're not properly
prepared so there's one Road in and out
of emerald Acres Cooperative it's a
mobile home community and the Oyster
River FL flows underneath that road
through a 7 foot high by 9 and 1/2t wide
elliptical metal
covert uh it also happens to Black to
block fish passage which is how it first
got on our radar and in 2007 you can see
by the photo it totally washed out
during the Patriots Day storm it also
got hammered the year before during the
Mother's Day
storm uh residents lacked emergency
access for almost a week and there was
an incident where a medical emergency
someone had to be carried you know by a
stretcher through the woods to get the
the proper care they needed and so it
was pretty terrifying for the h hundred
or so uh there's 100 or so homes there
for the residents of those
homes and so what happened next was that
in some emergency repairs they kind of
dragged the old Culvert back Upstream
slapped it back into place and uh kind
of moved on a group of Partners came
together to try to help replace uh that
old covert with a properly sized one
that would be able to accommodate the
next storm that was surely to come uh
and at that time this is 2009 it cost
the estimates were about
250,000 to to finish the job to get the
right size piece infrastructure in
place um unfortunately fell about
$25,000 short and it took us till
2023 to finish the job so this just
wrapped up in in October of this last
year by that time it was
$750,000 so the the damage the cost of
emergency repairs that had to happen in
the interm inflation Supply costs
increased contractor costs so that was
three times the cost by by waiting that
that amount of
time plus the stress on the community um
there's a on the backside there's um uh
some quotes by folks that that live
there and just kind of the constant
stress of having to go check on your
road during every storm to make sure you
weren't going to get stranded is is uh
is real for a lot for a lot of New
Hampshire residents
uh so you know again we either pay for
it now one and done or we pay for these
emergency repairs plus the inflated
future costs uh and this is just an
example you know we're working with New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
and and a hand full of municipalities on
a few of these but we can really only
work project by project um and to
commend the good work of Dees with that
that Culvert program which supported
four I believe it was four CT important
C projects it's it's valuable but
there's 21,000 CS in the state and not
all of them need to be fixed but a good
half of them are not the right size for
the rivers or streams passing through
and we're on the order of of hundreds
that are that really do need to be fixed
soon so it's a it's a bit of a scale
issue which is where a planning Council
like this can be have a lot of
forethought and help bring together all
the agencies the practitioners the
people out there on the ground
engineers and and all the players that
that got to really think through this
how do we kind of finally get ahead of
this instead of always trying to play
catchup um so the way we we accomplished
this project and there was a beautiful
Bridge put in by New Hampshire uh Bridge
contractor um which was a really
successful project so everyone was happy
um but it was pretty rag tag you know
there was a lot of players rling and it
took us 15 years to get it done and uh
and again we just uh didn't quite have
that kind of effective coordination
among state and local agencies and the
scientists and the day-to-day
practitioners so that's kind of what
we're moving towards so we can do this
thing a little bigger and a little more
scale thank you questions Mr
Thorne yes please represent Newman yes
thank you could you go back to your
comment there's 21,000 coverts in New
Hampshire and half of them
aren't quite so um
appropriate yeah there so there's a
stream Crossing assessment that's been
working its way through 21 or so
thousand covers in the state and they're
um evaluated for how they fit based on
the um the hydrology and the
geomorphology of the stream channel so
they a lot of our road infrastructure is
really old so it's not just that it that
a lot of them don't fit properly uh as
the gentleman from New Hampshire dot
said that they got to be bigger and they
got to go further out uh but they're
also old and failing in a lot of cases
uh you know metal rusted out CS like in
in the case here when they the excavator
lifted this one out of the ground there
was no bottom I mean it was it was like
it wasn't serving its purpose it just
kind of fell apart and crumbled on the
side of the road um so it's uh there
there's just a lot of Aging
infrastructure that was put in you know
50 or 75 or 100 years ago and it's just
not it's it's not up to the to the speed
thank you quick followup yes thank you
could I just ask is there a um an
organized schedule to evaluate these
things or a section of the state at a
time or how how does this work get done
yeah thank you for the question yeah
there is to to my understanding and I
don't serve on this um in this group but
there is inter agency work to go to
assess them uh kind of region or
Watershed by Watershed throughout the
state and I think they've made really
good progress and to to my understanding
it's kind of now in the phase of
finishing up assessing the the last ones
and then kind of help put them in order
but it's complicated because they're all
different asset owners some are the
state or town or or private uh
potentially so there's uh there's kind
of a a big body of work there to figure
out how to kind of where to
start thank you sir any further
questions yes please represent melin
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question if these CS are
repaired uh or replaced what's the life
expectancy of them on 100 or 200 year
storm yeah I I think the there's um you
know each case is a little bit different
my understanding is that a lot of the
concrete coverts have a lifespan of
somewhere 75 or or 100 years um I'm not
an expert so I I can't you speak to that
or I'm not an engineer excuse me so I
can't speak to that exactly but
somewhere in you know there's a hope
that a concrete Culver could last
somewhere about 75 years thank you any
further
questions seeing none thank you is there
anyone present wishes to speak a second
time or someone that wanted to speak
that had hasn't had the opportunity uh
to speak on Senate Bill
543 seeing none blue sheet blue sheet if
we could pass that along um yes please
represent
PFI could I speak with the dees person
again certainly do you want to bring him
forward do you want to speak
privately thank you for coming back up
absolutely yes yes sir thank
you I think the dees has always done a
great
job
okay I'm seeing this as a new level of
bureaucracy because I'm I'm always happy
with your
decisions
uh we pull pull you a little close just
pull right you hear me yes yeah I
okay
uh I just want to say thank you you you
you've done a great job and uh I hope
you continue to do it thank you I guess
the sounded like there was a little bit
of question about would this develop
another layer of bureaucracy within an
already um you know often bureaucratic
process um in fact I think at uh uh
Senator avard at a at a hearing last
week um I think he sort of misspoke but
he actually may have intended to call us
the department of bureaucracy um which
uh yeah anyway um so so I don't think so
I don't think that that's the case I
think that this you know and I and if
you look at our letter we do actually
think that if this commission is to go
or commit Council sorry if this council
is to go forward um that that the or the
f focus at the outset really should be
on making sure that the state agencies
are well coordinated and so I think that
that really is key and and that
hopefully reduces bureaucracy uh over
the long run but uh you know time will
tell but so thanks for the question I do
appreciate thank you um seeing none uh
no further I will uh is there blue sheet
coming forward
uh for society uh Matt Ley signed in in
favor and and um one of our speakers
from the conservation land Foundation
also uh speaking for uh no one
opposed uh with that um we will not be
executing this bill today and I will
call the hearing 543 to a close thank
you and for the committee this is our
only business that we have before us
today um I will um we are not in a
rush um as we were with the uh prison
bill from last week uh so I have not
scheduled out for next week uh we'll
look and see what the schedule is for um
house sessions going forward and perhaps
we can cohab habitate some time in there
to hold our executive session all right
any questions for myself please so as
far as you know there are no more Senate
bills coming over to us uh I was advised
that all the bills have been assigned
and when I checked this morning we have
no new surprises coming from the
Senate yay
yeah
right any anything
else I'm sorry to have taken you through
your lunch I never thought that we would
probably be this long and
uh yeah we will um so with that thank
you okay thank you